it's me Moulder I can't act good but I
sure am pretty the scene opens in
Miller's Grove Massachusetts where an
exterminator is assigned to eradicate a
cockroach infestation in the basement of
Dr Jeff eerl an alternative fuel
researcher during the process the
Exterminator lectures Dr URL about the
ancient origins of cockroaches tracing
back to the saluran period over 350
million years ago that's all well and
good says that girl but uh stop being a
creep and just do your job all right he
goes on to say that cockroaches can be
found in every corner of the world and
that there exists over 4,000 known
species according to him a single female
cockroach can produce over half a
million descendants he also regards them
as Flawless creatures as they can't be
killed by radiation but unlike human
beings they do not have cognitive
abilities moreover the Exterminator
tells Dr eel about his new pesticides
working like a fungus that not only
kills the infected roach but also so
passes on the virus to every other roach
it comes into contact with the homeowner
then walks upstairs thoroughly creeped
out leaving the Exterminator to finish
his job while working the man notices an
arrogant cockroach that resists his
pesticide because of this he knocks it
down to the ground and proceeds to crush
it underf foot but as soon as he Stomps
it he begins to succumb to anaphylaxis
he clutches his heart and collapses
against a wall while the roach crawls
out from under his boot unscathed a
short while later Dr aurl returns only
to find the Exterminator body covered
with roaches in the next scene we're
introduced to an FBI special agent named
Fox Moulder scl who seems to have
recently entered Miller's Grove in order
to investigate reported UFO sightings
there he pulls over his car at the side
of the highway and stares at the stars
in the sky the truth is out there scall
a few moments later he receives a phone
call from his co-worker Dana Scully who
is a medical doctor their conversation
is soon interrupted by the local
patrolling Sheriff named frass who
questions his purpose of staying there
upon learning of his identity fras tells
him about a series of roach attacks that
have taken place in the town not long
after the sheriff receives information
about the attack at Dr echl's residence
and FOX also accompanies him there upon
arrival Fox calls Scully to report on
the mysterious deaths caused by roaches
but she gives him a standard scientific
explanation that many people are
allergic to roaches and could have just
died from anaphylactic shock elsewhere
in town a group of three teenagers
engaged and drinking booze and inhaling
fumes produced by heated manure yeah
Chad pass me the poop bong just butt
chugging and doing poop bong rips amidst
this one of them sees a cockroach
crawling into an open wound on his wrist
which freaks him out in a desperate
attempt to remove the insect he resorts
to cutting his skin with a razor
unfortunately he accidentally sever an
artery and passes away due to fatal
bleeding shortly after Fox arrives at
the scene and contacts Scully once again
to report the incident they're smoking
out here scul after hearing about
it she explains that it is likely a case
of drug induced delusional parasytes a
condition that involves imaginary
Visions Scully has an answer for
everything however this time Fox
discovers a cockroach on the underside
of a piece of furniture proving that it
was not delusional when he attempts to
capture it for further analysis the
insect crumbles in his hand and the
sharp pieces cut his fingers in the
process this leads him to believe that
the insect is actually made of a
metallic substance bold prediction to
covy bold and stupid following this fox
seeks medical attention for his injured
hand at the hospital while the doctor
excuses himself to go to the washroom
Sheriff frass reveals to Fox that the
government under the guys of the USDA
has been breeding killer cockroaches in
a nearby facility a short while later
the doctor is found dead in a bathroom
stall the body is initially covered with
cockroaches that soon vanish before
anyone can witness them when reports it
to Scully she attributes the death as a
cerebral aneurysm that was brought upon
by aggressive defecation what it's crazy
Scot just then Fox and frass spot a
seemingly dead cockroach on a sink in
the bathroom as he reaches out to
capture it the Cockroach suddenly comes
to life and escapes down the drain later
that night fox goes to investigate the
secret government facility mentioned by
Sheriff frass before breaking in he and
Scully discussed the peculiar behavior
of the roaches over the phone with
Scully proposing a hyp hypothesis that
the roaches might be an invasive species
upon entering the facility Fox is soon
surrounded by numerous cockroaches but
they are thankfully the harmless ones
right then he is confronted by Dr Bambi
Baron balm a researcher from the
Department of Agriculture who is
studying cockroaches to develop more
effective methods of pest control after
introducing themselves Dr Bambi
expresses her interest in insects and
believes that some UFOs are actually
insect swarms flying through
electrically charged airfields else by
this point Fox's boner is absolutely out
of control after a brief interaction Fox
returns back to his hotel room and
contacts Scully in order to relay the
information gathered from Dr Bambi as
they go on conversing he admits to
having a strong aversion to Insects
Scully believes that most of the people
are scared of the insects but Fox
clarifies that his sentiment is not fear
but rather a deep-seated dislike he goes
on to share a past experience from his
childhood recounting how he let out a
scream when he saw an insect on body I
screamed like this SC in the midst of
their conversation Fox hears a scream
prompting him to rush to a room down the
hall it turns out to be another death of
a hotel guest caused by harmful
cockroaches upon thoroughly
investigating the dead body Fox
speculates that the guy died out of fear
when Scully learns of yet another death
she begins to wonder what is going on
and decides to head up there herself for
the further investigation after this
mder brings a cockroach from the hotel
room to Dr Bambi's research lab upon on
investigating it via microscope the
doctor thinks that this insect may be
mechanical that's what I thought says
Fox the boner fast returning with a
Vengeance she claims that she has seen
such insects only in science journals in
addition she tells him about an
artificial intelligence researcher named
Dr Alexander Ivanov who designs robots
that resemble and behave like insects
with this information in hand Fox visits
Dr ivanov's research facility in hopes
of uncovering more information about the
mysterious roaches of upon reaching
there a wheelchair-bound Dr Ivanov
briefs him about his robotic Works he
claims that his colleagues in artificial
intelligence have attempted to create an
autonomous robot for decades but they
have failed after not being able to give
human-like brains to the machines
according to the doctor the human brain
is too complex and computational but
insects merely react he further tells
him that he uses insects as his model
not just in design but by giving them
the simplest of computer programs the
two then discussed the possibility that
extraterrestrial intelligences could
send robotic probes to study other
planets as their conversation unfolds
Fox's boner is coming back and it's more
Awkward this time and he shows Dr Ivanov
his metallic roach legs and asks him to
inspect them in detail upon watching it
through a microscope Dr Ivanov is
rendered speechless he informs Fox that
the specimen is technology-wise vastly
superior to anything he has ever seen
and that it is beyond his comprehension
on the other hand Scully arrives in the
town and walks into a convenience store
only to find the residents in a state of
panic over roaches everyone is seen
scrambling for supplies and anti-ro
sprays just then two scuffling patrons
knock over a display of chocolate
candies and spill the chocolate balls
all over the floor the storg goers
mistake them to be more roaches which
freaks them out so they frantically flee
the scene Scully is disappointed by the
low intelligence of the average citizen
meanwhile Fox while departing Dr
ivanov's research facility catches
another Ro in the hallway and brings it
to Dr Bambi it's a present for you babe
but upon examining it she concludes that
it is a seemingly normal cockroach and
its genitalia is normal as well the
mention of metallic alien bug dong is
just too much for malder and he straight
up shoots in his pants in the midst of
their discussion Fox receives a call
from Scully who has found out that Dr
eerl was researching methane gas that is
derived from manure as an alternative
source of fuel she also claims that he
had been importing animal dung samples
from outside the country believing that
the Cockroaches are dung eaters she
suspects that some of them might have
accidentally shipped in some of the
samples as a result the roaches began to
spread throughout the town upon hearing
this fox speculates that the roaches are
actually extraterrestrial robotic probes
scal he believes that they are
technologically advanced enough to
generate methane fuel by consuming
manure an abundant energy resource
already exploited by some alien planet
that is filled with dung producing
creatures and Yep this is par for the
course in an episode of The X files
following this fox accompanied by Dr
Bambi goes to visit Dr eerl at his
research facility when they arrive at
the location Fox instructs her to stay
inside the car until he ensures that it
is safe inside as he enters the facility
he comes across some research contents
several cockroaches feeding on manure
while looking at it Dr eerl Who is now
turned into a hysterical and paranoid
State fires a shot towards him Fox tries
to stop him pointing out that he might
blow up the entire facility as the
methane gas is highly flam
however Dr eel who has been
unsuccessfully trying to escape these
roaches now feels that they are
following him due to which he remains
agitated in the midst of their
conversation they hear the Cockroaches
making weird noises Fox then informs him
of the Cockroaches that hiss by blowing
air through holes in their upper thorax
He suggests that they capture them for
further study rather than killing them
Dr eel believes that he has lost his
mind but Fox tries to comfort him by
saying that he just had a very stressful
day that has affected his ability to
think clearly however this only leads
him to think that Fox May somehow be a
cockroach so he pulls his gun on him in
the meantime Scully arrives at the scene
but she does not appear much delighted
to meet Dr Bambi she proceeds to enter
the facility in search of Fox and places
a call to him when Fox's phone rings Dr
eerl believes that he is making a tone
like the rest of the unusual roaches as
a result he Fires at Fox and his shots
rupture and ignite pipes containing
methane gas sensing the imminent danger
the FBI agents rush out of the facility
and manag to hide behind their car just
a moment before it explodes with Dr eerl
still inside the agents are unharmed but
are humorously covered in Pooh in the
aftermath of this event the police
arrived to clear the area Sheriff frass
informs the agents about several other
incidents fires and car accidents
resulting from the town's Panic not my
problem Chef not long after Dr Ivanov
also arrives at the scene of the
explosion and requests that fox lend him
the robotic roach specimens that he
showed him earlier there he meets with
Dr Bambi who shares similar interests as
his the two then leave with one another
discussing their interests in insects
and robots as the FBI agents see them
depart Scully jokes on the possibility
that the two doctors future Offspring
could have the solution to the mystery
of the robotic roaches later that night
Fox compiles his report on the case
wondering how Humanity would react to
the presence of insect-like robots on
Earth he also considers the possibility
of the next evolutionary step being a
species devoid of emotion merely
reacting to its environment while typing
Fox finds a giant cave cockroach on his
food plate and promptly crushes it with
an x file subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for
watching